كيف يمكن لالا ان تفهم المطلوب من خريجيه
كليات الحقوق في الولايات المتحده قبل
الممارسه المهنيه او حتى الانتقال من
ادخال نص سؤال الى ادخال صوره على سبيل
المثال كهذه وتجيب على ما يمكن طبخه من
هذه المكونات في الصوره مرحله متقدمه هنا
يوفرها الاصدار رقم اربعه من تشاتشي بي تي
الاخير فاين يكمن السر وكيف وصلت الاله
الى هذه القدرات الاجابه مشاهدينا في
اللانجوج مودرن او نموذج اللغه فمن خلاله
انتقلت القدره الحسافيه الحسابيه
للكمبيوتر الى الكلاميه ما يفعله هو
ببساطه التوقع والاحتمال وهنا التطور يكمن
في تقرير هامش الخطا بحفظه منها ومغول من
المعلومات في هذا النظام
كيف نبدا جمله مثل عاصمه السعوديه هي
سيجيب
الرياض والعربيه ان تعرف سيجيب تشاتشي
بيتي باكثر لكن هذا ليس كافيا تبقى عمليه
البحث هنا محدوده كونها تتعلق من الاساس
بالسياق وبما يسبق وما يلحق من كلمات
مدخله ومبنيه على التوقعات وهنا تظهر
الميورل نتورك او الخلايا العصبيه
الصناعيه ثوره في عام 2017 في الذكاء
الصناعي نعم هنا وصلنا
اذا كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا الخلايا من اهم
اختراعات هذه الخلايا المختلفه كانت خليه
تي التي ترمز الى خليه ترانسفورمرز او
الخليه المتحوله وهي التي
الموجوده في تشات جي بي تي نهايه اسم
النظام تتميز باعطاء الكلمه المفتاحيه
اهميه التركيز في البحث الذي يتطلع
المستخدم لاخذ اجوبته والنتيجه ثقه
وشميليه وفهم للنص والان للصوره وحتى
مقاطع الفيديو مع الاصدار الاحدث
بينما تحرز الصين تقدما سريعا في مجال
الذكاء الاصطناعي وروبوتات الدردشه تعمل
الولايات المتحده على تطوير استراتيجيات
جديده لمواجهه زخم تخصص الدوله المزيد من
الاموال للبحث والتطوير في مجال الذكاء
الاصطناعي كما تعمل على زياده شراكاتها مع
المؤسسات الاكاديميه والشركات التكنولوجيه
الرائده للترويج للبحوث الامريكيه على وطن
على ذلك تعمل الولايات المتحده لتقويه
مجموعه المواهب التقنيه لديها من خلال
الاستثمار في مبادرات تعليم العلوم
والتكنولوجيا والهندسه والرياضيات وتشجيع
المهاجرين الموهوبين على البقاء في البلاد
بالاضافه الى تعزيز التعاون الدولي مع دول
مثل كندا والمملكه المتحده لتجميع الموارد
وانشاء جبهه ابحاث اكثر فعاليه في هذا
المجال
واشنطن تستكشف ايضا تدابير التنظيميه
لضمان ان تلعب شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي
الصينيه نفس المعايير الاخلاقيه مثل
نظراتها الامريكيه
هدف الشركات الامريكيه يبقى الحفاظ على
قدرتها التنافسيه في سباق التكنولوجيا
العالمي